[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
day of GameSpot play for all charity
streams today
we've opened the door to the past it's
2014
what a door it is o greatest orrible I'm
joined by step board and cam Robinson do
you want to do it I kind of do yet
welcome to another episode of top 5
scary mods of all time with me cam and
with me as always is it's uh it's Seb
and joining us for a very special
episode I'm sorry we totally stole your
partner I see I know cuz I started doing
it then I was like wait let's just get
the get the lats in to do it it's so
nice to see you guys I haven't seen you
since did I see you I didn't see it
Christmas there's nothing you since you
left us you were doing it you were just
gone one day bye I'm out of here but
well obviously doing this big charity
event here in GameSpot and we thought
who better to get in to help us out then
my two favorite Jax zhabin cam and
special guest
Kevin ban nod to to revisit when the
greatest games of all time and so to
look at the greatest mods of all time
but I'd be the greatest game spot show
of all time no it had its window for
sure for sure we enjoyed it by the way
cam and I are are safe the reason we're
on two cameras is we are in the same
room technically but far apart because
we're enemies yes it's largely the
enemies thing yeah so distance things
actually made our relationship easier
yeah so it's just I can force that yeah
they say absence makes the heart grow
fonder and now we can tolerate each
other again so so in Skyrim you can see
that we've got our first mod and the mod
is that we've got a piece of texture
that appears in the corner this is my
fav read three
seconds assay reminds you that immersive
armor configuration has indeed finished
so and don't worry it's finished guys
but we'll see if we can figure out how
to get rid of that and but yeah we we
thought that as lucy as you rightly said
these are the some of the greatest mods
that have ever been on skyrim that we
want to show but they're also our
favorites and the fact that like because
as anyone knows who's modded skyrim as
soon as at this point you must have so
many mods on that once you go down one
modding path you can't necessarily put
any other mods on or they clash and it
just doesn't start so we've gone down a
certain route with our favourite mods
some of them this is gonna surprise you
are really silly but they're still
excellent so i think in total we're
running somewhere in the ballpark of
about 180 mods so yeah it's it's pretty
full and wood ice described it as stable
definitely not understand note no way at
all but it is working and it's pretty
nice yeah this game unless you forget it
was 20 2011 2011 that it came out 11 so
it's it's nearly nine years old which is
frightening and yeah it's still I mean
obviously this is mod e2 crazy but it's
it well looking pretty good
I mean bear in mind that obviously
pumped through a stream whenever you
want it to look really nice we're just
gonna hold really still and just let
those pixels sort crease get a real a
real tasty look at just how nice it's
looking this if you if you haven't met
Kevin vine Lord before we should just
explain how we definitely did starve the
show yeah yeah god of sorts and never
speaks nope originally hatched from an
egg yeah largely mechanical Lord behind
Kevin van Lord yeah he's the ultimate
and way to show off Skyrim mods because
he's basically impervious to all damage
technically he is uh you know with in
Skyrim he is of Nord
sort of ilk hence his name but his name
is namesake was also a member of
GameSpot at one point as well our
colleague Ken van Ord and we have gay I
know
I know some say he made that move
because he was inspired by Kevin van or
it by some I mean me I say that but I
think it's possible we when we first
created Kevin we we decided to give him
like a shaved head but I mean one of the
mods I know we have installed here KS
hairdos cam so we did if you want start
off by giving giving him a magnificent
haircut haircuts have just been allowed
in the UK oh yes I mean we didn't do
this
legally I have mine booked for next week
I have never had so much hair in my life
is that true
I I don't think I've ever had as much
hair no Mike the longest mine has been
for about three years I should say off
the bat we are raising money for charity
we've got the links on the page right
now so it's bitter ly /gs BLM to donate
to black lives matter and to donate to
direct leave it dot ly /gs - co vid we
have people in the chat already applies
as Kevin looks younger now or is he
older the Benjamin Button effect is
confusing yes well Kevin van Lord as we
all know ages in Reverse so as he gets
older he looks more youthful eventually
he will condense into a small child and
then become a singularity and that's the
end of the universe
oh but it's a good point actually does
Thank You Barry he's coming super
youthful I think it's cuz he's got
freckles so yes this mod is giving
freckles and cheekbones my word look at
those cheekbones
do you know years ago that guy who got
arrested but he was really really hot
and he was called converse there's a hot
felon lit going on well don't worry I'm
gonna change that up with a new hairdo
so Seb actually no Lucy tell me stop
when we find out here a hairdo that you
like okay so we can have this camera in
carroll of Rivia this monstrosity oh
yeah this one yeah okay I think the big
squares gonna quad are you good for the
for the the color as well oh I'm very
sort of like I didn't give any options
there they're like mousy brown
you can choose to color Rowney silver
looks like it looks like he's he's gone
on that he's on trend and he's gone for
the silver so I kind of I kind of like
that I think it also works with his the
rest of his outfit we're gonna like the
Platinum silvery look yeah okay okay
cool right enough we find it handsome
lads ready it's sort of like a flat of
sorts at the back there we should we
should also can I shout out the the
incredible efforts that you guys have
achieved so far in your your charity
totals are insane so it's really so good
so yeah we're just we're just happy to
be here to lend a hand for a couple of
hours and and get involved very happy to
do so Kevin of course has no emotions
but if he did yeah well I was gonna say
emotions and not what Kevin is known for
but I feel like he has a a lingering
sense of pride about being involved you
know but he would never miss it so it's
a feeling often confused with pride we
understand it as rage so said you have
actually so we have actually got a list
Lucy of mods I came to the altar and
also akin to the old star of the show we
have more than five even though it was
in the name of the show top 5 greatest
mods is somewhere in the ballpark of 12
it like 1 2 3 4 5 yeah 11 in said what
mod shall we start us off with um I
think first off rain should go and grab
ourselves an old compact North companion
yeah have Lucy here yes but another
better or worse than least I would say a
hairier companion oh it's maybe the
longest your hands ever being but Harry
is still okay some things slide well
this one's feline so a nice
well yeah I mean we've actually got two
compact Oh oh yeah well let's start with
that one
Oh which one we can certainly start with
it wait I think the other one is better
okay well tell me where they'll tell me
all right so we're gonna first off go to
Rifton say himself always happens like
we'll go to this place and then I'm like
I forgot wherever hey you got it
first time first time since that I've
missed you Justin
where have you been Fraggle to me yes
the boys are back Chris Thomas is in the
pool hustle hustle up man why miss you
guys and I've already got the crash
counter okay so we need two counters is
gonna be the head counter and the crash
counter the crash counter is probably
going to win welcome to a very moody
rifton's extremely moody
Oh Mike controllers ready for some
reason just carry on where are we going
I think first off do you want to take us
over to the beam barb
I would love to a fine establishment I
remember which yes you think you know
who it's gonna be
yes right it's one of the greatest it's
not a B I wish it was one of the
greatest companions ever to be added to
Skyrim via mods that's fine and hey
guess let's find out if it works because
it's a mod from old Skyrim is he there
there is it's dovabear and he's adorable
look at me don't stop turning away come
back on quite the crowd you remember
this place being this route I can't even
get close to social distance folks come
on anxious just to look at I know I've
not seen this many people don't he's
really he's getting a bit mad
come on dovabear here we go
I want to trade with you bear amazing
just got lots of I see what he had money
remember if you feed
can't you like feed these to him and
then he goes like super saiyan or
something
so do I need to take them and then give
them back to him ah this is his stash
yeah maybe let's take them anyway well
I'm stealing all of his things
yeah a lot of booze let's go do a bear
see if he's gonna follow so this this
mod dovabear dovabear companion by train
whiz and Friends is technically from
skyrim legendary edition not from Skyrim
special edition so it's the original
version not the sort of the upgraded
64-bit version he refuses to leave the
pub well it is a crowded pub this is
this is actually what it's like in the
UK right now yeah yeah and everyone is
doing it responsibly all right but good
they say yeah this pretty much is what
it's like there's a there's a pub at the
end of my Road and like the moment it
was allowed to be open oh my god city I
did get him to come out before like he's
definitely he's having too much fun
Canada come on condo he's seat poor guys
drunk oh oh get back inside inside yeah
that was the sound of a have a future
mod actually really a past okay so come
with me adventure awaits us over there
he doesn't come on oh come on buddy
no what he's a good boy
no adorable yeah I love I love the Hat
the helmet even yes oh you know we may
need to just jump ahead to this next mod
that's fine that's fine let me go
outside that's the toot-toot of fate
yeah yep
J locks yes you are playing Elder
Scrolls its Skyrim a very heavily modded
version of Skyrim very very yes yes
aggressively aggressively so this is a
but this is like him we've added a few
extra miles but this
is a motive save a version of Modi's
save that we are currently using on our
own channel anyway so this is still
being played we just added a few extra
ones we're doing like the birth of Kevin
bundle Channel yeah the origin story
Kevin so he's so he's horribly old old
yeah I guess and weirdly has hello who
does agent reverse yeah exactly
okay so we're looking for this other mod
so I definitely heard I heard him -
Tooting around you know what he'll
figure it out you're fine okay let's
just go on to the next modern okay okay
so we've got do a beer so where to you
know okay so let's think where would be
a good place to go um I mean just for a
little like a little fun one maybe
heading down to the water's edge and see
if we can go find some crab oh yeah okay
yeah let me just find the map okay so
I'm not sorry there's water right behind
ya about turn this is just a stupid one
this way and then after that we needs a
head to the outskirts of rifted so I
mentioned rift in Whiterun I mention
seed how many people in the chat are
still playing Skyrim to this day
thousand times you can pretty much play
Skyrim on anything these days even your
toaster we play on an Alexa don't yeah
you can exactly exactly
I had to tell mine is so big we really
get to know who's still actually playing
because I'm pretty sure didn't didn't
Pete Hines put put the kind of nail to
the coffin of rumors that we should be
expecting a sequel anytime soon or like
didn't they say the starfield was gonna
be first yes that's what he said yeah
it's double bear still with me yeah of
course he is faithful companion we
should definitely get him into some
combat as soon as oh we won't really
crabs oh wait yeah okay okay by the way
if here's a question are we allowed to
curse on this stream cuz if not we
should probably turn around go on it's a
Tuesday it's a Tuesday morning for most
of you'll be cursing
okay one of the marijuana maybe turn
your volumes down a little bit I mean
you're all working from home so it's
fine don't worry about it
oh wow there's a lot of beautiful elk we
are moving around very quickly we should
let the people see the vistas all right
am I am I going the right way as well
no I've gone entirely the wrong way okay
in a fast travel to the water's edge
because I'm so bad I give you a clear
skies console as well if you like we can
brighten it up because this game while
it while it obviously is beautiful when
it's all Moody and everything looks
clear sky really makes it give me they
give it the old SW SW one zero one one
zero one now it's 1 0 e o 1 double e
mm-hmm this is why you watch to see
codes put in wait for one hour Oh
beautiful around these crabs remember
the outside no once everyone in this
still playing by the way oh great oh man
I was playing last night mister yova
yoga care you have a cat I'm on Skyrim
today is wagging today I am Leon Dee
still playing but not as often as I'd
like
Elias I'm still playing Skyrim after all
these years it's still my favorite game
how many hours do you have in it now
because I remember when you left games
but there was like over a thousand I
think on that PC it's difficult that way
yeah tricky because between all of the
accounts that we've had because we've
played on console on both consoles on
our own personal steam accounts on both
se and le and of course our old the the
game sports team account the Wiis to run
the show on and I it would be thousands
buying it from multiple thousand four
hours no spend in real life yes yeah and
I would say it's it's probably nothing
on like a seasoned MMO player for sure
like but it must be must be the game I
played morning
yeah I can't find any of these crabs
there you promise me you know what let's
just go to Whiterun let's get a white
run because we can jump ahead and so the
crabs will appear when they were bears
getting hungry
the grant was a fight probably so where
do we go white run let's go to white run
and sure let's but go to the outskirts
you know to like the the media read okay
that area sir just yeah yeah there's
good leisure for the media yeah and
again in the meter II he said he's a
bear like he's gonna love the meter II
well he did have a lot of Mead back to
get all office yeah he needs some more
economy also Haitian and Skyrim are the
only reasons I bought PC look what you
guys did
I'm so sorry no that's good if you
bought the PC when the show started that
pcs probably a little bit past its yeah
prize yeah Oh
said there's a chicken here there I test
it you can just make sure it's working
just check the odds-on yeah from a
distance right here it's working
explosive chickens is still on you know
what that's also a Nelly mod as well I
couldn't find a functioning Skyrim
special edition version of exploding
chickens that would successfully launch
you into the sky yeah strange where we
just like the ragdoll physics wouldn't
work or something and it wouldn't it
would refuse to kick you up into the air
which is the whole point okay a fairly
sad admission of mine though is that
like for all of my love of modding
Skyrim I have never actually made or
really even attempted to make a mod sad
what is this I won the cam what is it
it's a charge why Sir Bruce Bruce I just
sorry breeze I can write what mod is
this said you wanna get mods but is this
madness
it's Bruce what's the mod called this is
called right I think it's called
rideable monster mounts SE so do we have
featured this many times I have a vague
memory of this can do everything is but
the good thing is we're actually uh cam
you're riding away from the the other
companion thanks i solid they were they
were horrendous there's one or two for
sure for sure amazing alright Lisa you
can gonna have to decide what our
amounts of choice is gonna be and we are
we have a lot okay so I see a few here
and just dismounting from Bruce
as brucey I only occurred to me that
Ross Bruce is the name of the guy from
oh my god I know isn't it I thought
that's what the joke was that Bruce
Bruce the shock from fighting me like
Fisher friends not reasonably him yeah
no I
he's hideous it's like a gremlin that
was fed after midnight yeah and then if
you keep heading that way cam oh think
you can write can I write this guy yep
totally amazing all the mates yeah cuz
they've got the game of course the only
man you had really was a dinosaur yeah
he's getting better in there
Oh cam I'm like you barely scratches the
dragger I think this is definitely one
of my favourite mods it's such a simple
mod and it does so much oh yes I love
the ground shake this is great they do
move this chickens
no no fortunately no oh sorry Kay don't
mind me
he's graceful lumpy I was gonna say just
can he run actually right over there
no I can talk to him no that is full
speed I believe mmm well I mean he is my
favorite just because I get to song but
I think I think Bruce which is stompy
right so far all right well we can we
can ride briefs on over to to see the
others there's lots of Raptor there of
some sort can ride Manny - Manny oh it's
kind of awful what is what is that
what are you sir
slowed it's a cross between a sloth and
the toad I'm assuming and it's
horrendous no and then a giant King it's
gonna come oh it's one my screen it
looks more like
you don't the troll in the dungeon from
her yeah oh no as in the astral yeah
yeah kind of like Oh kind of like the
the troll in Moria yeah yeah yeah yeah
keep tall there's so many veggies the
tiger that's right a ball yeah basically
all the creatures from from the game you
can a bunch more creatures see oh said
like what is this I think that's the
crossover mode where one mod has met
another which makes me think if you were
to jump down cam huh easily done please
please oh all right exactly Oh what is
this gonna work
am I not really I'll kinda can you can
you pan the cam back like yeah yeah like
flicking and I remember it's one it
there you go I mean we're even toggle is
that there's a man a man riding a tank
engine which one is this so alright this
is really useful dragons right I mean
which tank engine oh that's Henry isn't
it no no no no help help chat help you
know which one is red which is the red
one Thomas is mercy that's all I know
and then there's dead is it I'm gonna
click away to calm the Fat Controller
anymore I don't know thinking should we
just say the control I'm stuck on
something yeah so these these these mods
aren't exactly lower frames
generally it's Grange's ok well I'm
gonna leave James right there I'm
actually after all that I think we
should proceed Maitlis it's good to know
they exist now that said let's head on
to the next mod set what do we have next
ok is there one that we can take do a
bear to call that uh I mean to be honest
well the the shout mod that I wanted to
give us is the one that absolutely
crippled yeah crippled our game so why
don't we just go and fight some Giants
okay a couple donations that we had
Anthony Begley
twenty-five dollars to buy clothes
matter and five bucks from CR pate
love to see this reunion this show is
what got me into PC gaming strictly to
mod Skyrim thank you guys thanks very
much those donations really appreciate
these and of course we will continue to
show off mods throughout the stream but
if there's any questions you have about
Skyrim things you've always wondered any
mods you're wondering for because we're
running a lot of other mods under the
hood that aren't part of what we're
featuring so do let us know if you have
any questions done a few too many
crossover mods that may have upset them
well we could just fight a mammoth oh
that sounds Oh
dovabear just appearing out of the
ground the ground is shaking that's
right nearby yeah
but I don't see I don't see any Giants
where are all the enemies let's bring
one in bring one in fine fun it's the
great definitely give it the old help
the great thing about scaring you can
just do this helped giant player dot
place at me FF 0 0 1 2 e 3 - 5 there you
go oh whoa Giants wow yeah larvae don't
were very shy this is why he's the
greatest companion he didn't even need
Kevin's help you can just you can just
take them all on so one of the mods I've
added is called Giants plus so he's like
no oh no I shouldn't have let him I
shouldn't have let him be alright
oh is he he's gonna be ok is he gonna he
better be okay Kevin's gonna just be
avenged like it gets better so they
never kill the kill move seems to be
just like exclusively it's Justin's yeah
taking a giant knees so I think the kill
cam is is getting a little bit confused
because the the mob that we've got here
is giants Plus which basically makes
Giants into actual Giants rather than oh
these taller than usual they are taller
than evil yeah
fatigue I see you do a bear you go they
are such good friends and I think you
got him
no he's coming back you know he's not
done he's not gonna talk really bad or
I'm missing headsman's ax okay so am
what's next sir we've a photo Giants
they are destiny plus a fine launch
let's why don't we head in to Whiterun
itself okay and this guy off let's see
if we can go Smith ourselves some some
better armor because at the moment we're
just wearing like yeah Kevin looks like
he's ready for a party you know I'll be
nothing in the blood but yeah looking
very fancy okay so you won't even get
some better armor yeah so if we head
into what oh good he finally said oh
yeah he's fine can you do something for
me oh yeah you can ask him to do stuff
so you can like like can you drink this
potion doesn't always work but you
should we can work up to him drinking
the potion okay let's go to wearin and
while we load in if we get a loading
screen oh it should have been fairly
close to Whiterun yeah if we get a
loading screen I urge you to read some
of the comments in the loading screen so
go on see if I can open the cheddar it
goes so well with I grew what's been
called shia graph does legendary loading
screens so she growth is the is the
Daedric god of like mischeif in in the
world of Skyrim so at least I believe
that's it is mischeif isn't it or
madness yeah I think it's madness
so this well first of all cam this is
JK's Whiterun that we're looking at
that's right so we slightly tweaked it
like you'll notice that sort of bit over
the entrance wage there is all new bit
and there's very I don't know what it
this
structure over the entrance way that
sort of triangular things buying
fortification so we've added a bunch of
bits and pieces into here and I think
one of the reasons that the the other
venue that we were in the bean bob was
so busy that we've got another mod on
although I kind of lost water that's
cool
get these a lot of just random dead ends
of Skyrim like the laborers well I've
got the immersive citizens mod on as
well which is supposed to improve the
sort of the citizens they only have like
50 clear what is that I think so
think that's why you're the pub that's
very well I thought we should go and
craft ourselves from new armor oh I've
gone past it because we've got immersive
armors installed as well as you can tell
Intel from the corner flashing to
apologise for that I don't know why
right there yeah okay blacksmith Forge
okay so I think we should basically yell
to done well we'll need to probably
bring a few things in here but okay
should have most of our options unlocked
so you can well you've gone through
everything there you can go through the
the armor instead okay so there's the
usual kinda hide our in leather oh
there's some different one shell bug
helmet yeah that's always nice oh yeah
there's loads of capes if you like Kate
just forget about it look I love the big
fashion statement tribunal armor birth
is this feel like a cape would go nicely
there you go that's fancy
oh I mean if we just find the one we
like or just console come on it in
clearly shall we wear this this is the
modern way bringing the tribunal armor
unarmored robe okay
actually this is difficult when you're
in because it's all the text yeah you
got this help
yeah bribe you know tribe you know hey
ye there we go
oh that's all hoods we need to hey job
of it don't we yeah okay so this is bit
mass I hope you guys enjoy watching me
type into a console this you know what
if you like if you like modding this is
gonna be old news to you yes
that's 2/3 which which color you going
for Oh what
let's go for it let's go for M D let's
go for the blue the blue okay right
there you got that was the boot
yeah okay so now you know grab a rope as
well a hood and well we'll need the rope
as well for sure okay so we need 2603
sorry 2602 okay 3187 almost yeah okay
good
yep and then the robe no I was gonna say
Romeo yeah okay yeah is 2602 26 or 231 8
see everyone 8c okay and then there's a
huge up oh man there's so many let's
let's let's let's just be mental yeah
let's grab the mantle I think so
what does it matter stand what this mod
is let's give it a go over your
fireplace well usually it's a Garmin is
it is it anything to do with that line
in tonight's tale where he is talking
about what he's gonna do when he wins
the the honor of the princess about
placing her upon the mantle and I always
thought as a young child that did mean
mounting her above the fireplace
well then none of them worked
so let's try crafting them do they know
that's going very well um okay so yeah I
have no idea why but let's just one
heeds we need troll fat and leather they
didn't come into your inventory no way
alright very strange I don't think I did
anything wrong
cleared up oh I placed it me they're
probably on the floor amazing I'm still
excellent at this game hey well I guess
it didn't work really all on the floor
around me I love to think that many
people in the chat knew exactly where
signed I just like come on cam they're
at your feet
okay okay we have them I wondered why it
wasn't giving me the error message but
it also wasn't giving me the in your
inventory message well it's not very
blue is it I guess I know where I'd put
the red one yeah we're gonna be clashing
but because we don't need them at all
okay look at that hmm that rather
fetching need a different weapon as well
as headsman's ax is not the big sword
that mounted with sheath is some sort of
like wizardy mage vibe going on with
this this particular set is this for
immersive armors is it yeah I think so
sounds good right okay well that's
another one where two that were bare and
by double bare I mean so I'm just trying
to find out where we get there's a spelt
home that and you know what while we do
that why don't we go and get our other
followers as well oh yeah okay so again
a back to Rifton we need to Ripton all
the best friends are in Riften
well the best friend Joe that's you
what's this [ __ ] okay oh this is so
pretty
Dobby wise may lurk in every guy's oh
this games loads too quick we'd have
enough mods on clearly oh dude there's
two all right so where to I think you
wanna go pretty much straight ahead like
directly across up there okay that would
explain why your controller was rumbling
Oh Justin sound of choo-choo trains okay
up here up here yeah and then to the
right do you know my way into prisons
when it when I play Skyrim its entire
it's just constantly that moment in Lord
of the Rings McCandles like I have no
memory of this place that is my
experience vibrating controller as well
oh man I'm like a magic sheet of mugs
how do you remember them all which how
do you remember all the mods yeah like
how do you remember which ones you've
done or which ones you haven't done
in truth and this was the case when we
were still making the show in GameSpot
we didn't we actually refute mods and
people like how come you're doing this
mod again and we're like again because
of excellent reason it's our girlfriend
there were I remember there were times
where we had like like particular
favorites at the time I remember we we
were really into this set those
basically this mod creator that was
making the a Midian Bourne series which
basically a Midian born armors a Midian
born weapons many more on everything and
like basically everything they did was
incredible and this looks like a new and
you character here is okay I'm picking
what don't worry famously good at this
oh god I don't actually think you need
to bust him out of there but it's no no
no he's in there by his own choice he
he's he pays rent being there but I
can't speak to is that I think he is
chatting to you just not coming up on
the subtitles he's probably not got no I
think I pissed this guard off yeah
you've got a bounty on you now this is
five gold come on
guard I'm rich yeah okay let me just
Wade overlook it oh yeah i'm thane of
course that's the great thing about
skyrim when you're thin you can just be
like i may have committed a petty crime
but well you remember them above the law
there is so there's a little letter
about him being there if you want to go
and check it out you left there behind
you by d my knee
your other way on the way in basically
okay okay yeah here it's on that table
uh-huh let's just go first person crazy
Khajiit read crazy cat eats the crazy
Khajiit in cell one is not to be
disturbed he paid us good money for that
cage so don't go bothering him if he's
still here in a month I think we should
enforce a little rent increase I doubt
we'll get the chance though you've all
seen the way he looks won't be surprised
if he tries to end his life soon
you see him in a particularly suicidal
mood get in there and stop him he's been
using the key we gave him so if you need
if you need in there in a hurry use the
spare in the broken strongbox above the
fireplace there you go
a dead man can't pay rent warden
Norton's Wow
so above the fireplace all right the way
bear doing over there buddy I love you
but you're in my way doing that we're
gonna replace you as a companion you
down here very pleased oh oh I just
found this dearest I should have used
down after I can't imagine there are
many fireplaces in the cells huh
strongbox hey unlock strongbox magic
perfect okay let's let him out ways even
picking easy hey pal Inigo is inigo
montoya
maybe we kill this father okay I like it
why did you have a bug in the jars it's
mr. dragonfly I believe ya so said why
why is Inigo one of your favorite
companions go
I think apart from the fat least is to
cool Khajiit I think it is his
personality beyond all of the other like
basically all the characters that they
created in Skyrim in the beginning all
had a basically a fairly common gruff
personality yeah and all your followers
certainly had that so he's just like
just a crazy dude that's just like I'm
up for whatever and all of his lines are
always really really fine plus he has
this I think he he has this like really
close relationship with his dragonfly in
a jar which I think you can we've got
like a console command that we can
position it like on on him as he like
runs around yeah
wait is in like
yeah like mr. dragonfly I've taken him
okay yeah oh cool
I need you really need some armor can we
give him just hit any thoughts okay I'll
go back any thoughts
dovabear is getting jealous quiet over
there I can't even hear him you need
some time yeah I can turn sour good idea
there we go yeah that's pretty good idea
settings gameplay oh it's inside audio
is it no no yeah yeah there's a really
nice it was like some sort of general
consensus and where you hide the
subtitles toggling games but anyway
let's try again any thoughts beat to me
okay so it's just constant like quips
and observations as you run around it's
gear Sakhalin alright well let's get it
let's see which of our followers is
gonna come with us hopefully both yeah
do we have a model for that yeah I think
you can have more than one by default
anyway let's see who comes with us oh
well so far you can always bring
dovabear back in later when I need him
alright so why is the dragon we're
hearing it here but we are hearing it
yeah okay well let's hit let's head back
outside and see if we can hips on the in
world map there we go see if we can get
the dragon to come to us so there's also
we so for our next mod as well we need
to look for at home I do not know where
oh did I not try and come with us cuz it
was the last finally the last one we
right maybe he was the one that was just
too tootin outside the front door don't
worry I'm still here dude okay where's
this dream is to forget I'm Tim in a
team it's it's in one of three places oh
yeah this yo cam do either you know
where castle tower is in skyrim i don't
know where it is
Karthus search Arcadia's cauldron and
mist veil keep I'm just checking all the
castles castle tower is in solitude
solitude it is okay I know where that is
what's up here
solitude in like in cell in solitude it
is the large fortress which acts as the
headquarters of the Imperial Legion well
it's taking us all around Skyrim which
is what I'm all about
Whistlestop tour right so I think yeah
yeah yes solitude is another one where
we put in a bunch of mods for just like
the general look at the place as well
let's head inside the winking Skeever
for a moment like this this will be
another round bar I reckon I hope so
so Rebecca Ford lovely Rebecca from
Digital Extremes were playing warframe
with her yesterday she donated 145 to
each cause amazing thank you so much
really generous thank you very much this
is the winking schemer and it's actually
winking as well thanks he is gross
okay this bar is less crowded alright
I'll talk about with us they what
specifically that bear okay so we're
going into the castle right yeah so we
are looking for a table in the courtyard
of Castle dour this has changed usually
the steps you know the steps are there
you just got to go through the gate
reverse looking around up here right you
can go here as well this is new though
yes so we're looking for a table at 8
yeah at home on a table in the courtyard
Castle doubt nice I guess it's up here
it's the right isn't it this is this
whole areas but yeah it's completely
changed
which mod is this I think this is still
part of let me get my ultimate list of
ultimate destiny courtyard okay home I
see at home maybe I'm the dexterous in
you yes
Oh pick it up so you can't also read it
would you like it I mean we can
certainly do that read the book bear
come on
we definitely need to get ya know if I
need to get any go some some clothes
I'll give him some it's like alright so
let me read this book first one thing at
a time so this was extra sin ye there we
go what that we learn a new spell
clumsiness I don't need a spell for
that's my natural state of being
I was a shape broke my toe a couple
weeks ago what tripped over my Ethernet
cable
what's she reconnected made of and had a
very very big bruise on it and it's that
was about five weeks ago and it's only
just stopped hurting so I think yeah man
break yeah yeah I did the same thing
like I mean back in December I first
fell off my bike and broke my hand and
then I kicked the corner of my bed
really hard so I've been spaced it like
two weeks and I was wrong with me that's
what it was like when I came off the
bike oh it's all over you just do this
[Laughter]
say this many the greatest modes of all
time like you hold it down it does this
okay alright okay this is great
stairs okay just bury me okay
bear with me okay bear with me alright
here we go
see now you getting it
this is gonna great what so I hope you
guys are in for another hour and 10
minutes of us just doin this
it's really awful actually can I do
anything interests like back it is so
basic as soon as you tap it you've
become and ragdoll mode so if we can
yeah what what else could we be doing
Pike Hrothgar maybe I do this and then I
you can swing your sword swing in a bowl
all right this is actually an excellent
mud okay you want to go to high Hrothgar
yeah and um it says like the insurance
fraud minigame from Saints Row 3 exactly
all right through the world okay let's
go let's just give this new spell a
whirl
did not disappoint no I could even get
ya if you go to throughout the world we
made there may be another I feel like
it's easier to fall off high Hrothgar
though without going to the pub exactly
yeah there you go
the debut love you we do all of you your
tongue your sisters always the spleen
alright well it's you know I can you see
this weird texture that appears there's
something about the night I don't know
you which I think it might be the Eid
I did it almost like a denim yeah thanks
to every yeah I've nice it in the
lighting screen there is something a
little a little off about the the dark
smoky part of morning scarab do you have
all these weird things you're like yeah
yeah I know he's a bug or a feature he's
don't know a little of both okay so this
is normally the home of Paarthurnax we
should probably bring him in because I
think he might be a particularly okay
yeah I'll doing who's the voice of Weepu
I don't know I spell there right no I'm
looking to my voice but hey it is
spelled P double a double a yeah that's
where I'm going wrong P double a are th
you are Oh
pather neck
hey hey up place at me I mean to us one
yeah and then PC so three see yeah five
seven yeah see space one you only not
one of them fine
Oh God here is okay just as I remember
it's bollocks he looks like he ever look
better [ __ ] he's he's one of the good
ones though so I'm shocked but we can we
can throw ourselves off here I was
trying to find out which were they the
mods that made um
solitude look the way it did and what
were you gonna say they see I'm just
looking at the Skyrim voice cast yeah
incredible
hey no idea that's one side I was in it
um Christopher Plummer Catelyn Catelyn
Stark Michael Hogan who is um Colonel
Tigh from Battlestar Galactica really
yeah Oh Charles Martin oh sorry is path
enact so Mario is the voice of partner
that's amazing I'm trying to get high up
so I can also I suppose on their home oh
no he's begun okay okay okay
were there anything else for such wasn't
oblivion other than the obvious ones or
was it because I feel like Patrick
Stewart over and over again also um
r.i.p to to max von sydow who was the
voice of Esbern Ennis he did all of the
trailers oh really
yeah he died in March this year yeah he
was if if you know you come from
oh no he go it's begun
it's like their business in see we can
just make the whole way down like hot
rod oh yeah oh do make it all the way so
the only famous voice actors in oblivion
Patrick Stewart Sean Bean Linda
Carter under Terence Stamp
oh no jonathan pryce I recognize that
name he was in know I don't it's a
different man oh that was mine this the
the rest of the screen guys I wonder if
we can combine this with exploding
chickens
oh yeah well as in as in like what's it
set a chicken off like a chicken fuse
yeah punching it can I know a fire wait
no I can't remember we're still not down
here we go this is gonna be good one
let's wait for it it looks like it's in
slo-mo
it's alright he's Kevin Thunder fine
good commuting this is just his version
of a massage I only got a very sight so
if you want cam I can actually show off
one of the like practical mods right why
don't I do in the war though oh wait oh
um it says can you do whirlwind sprint
then rag doll oh that is a good idea
oh man oh yeah with the bringing it with
the ideas okay where's my shirts do we
have it yes right the bottom oh we've
only got one one word for it though it's
it's enough okay although they're both
quickly save it yeah also I mean I'm in
the wrong man you are totally messed us
up guys all right next we check in so
that one well in sprint always
clumsiness it's under spells though yeah
oh you can get it in the all category oh
we go there yeah
okay can I put on no always goes to the
shoulder bug didn't work good stuff it
was my fault apologize oh come on get up
get up get up man
okay yeah so I'm gonna wear with Sprint
and then change and then okay using
favorites right
No
maybe yeah we're open sprint Oh what am
i doing Zeb you know this do i yeah okay
sprint communist yes like co-op or
something Oh genius I should have done
that off the top of the throw the world
oh my word
so you can for the next mod we need to
well I mean really we could go into any
city because we need to go and have a
chat with a couple of guards okay
and where can I see if we can encourage
them to give us the famous line oh right
yes yeah so we can either go to to the
guy in white run or we can go to a
different town Lucy do you wanna pick us
a town I see them up you may so we have
such towns as dawn star winterhold
helm mark our favorite on the side there
Rorick stared at big enough to kind of a
town car really a town well is it not
like a yeah more fallow every mark
that's mark off everything it's cool
winter hold honestly I mean oh
Winterhold
went to hold is up I mean I knew that
maybe a frosty north it reminds me it
will make it reminds me of home no we
don't even get a snow there anymore
thanks global warming I've never been to
your part of the North Lucy really never
know I think that's one of the only
parts the UK I've never ever ever been
to you should barely be Valley yeah
barely
you've been to Glasgow and Edinburgh
once right I went to Aberdeen for a yes
tree oh my god I'm stuck we need to get
out use a new companion and
literally can't move Oh what if I can
lie down except it didn't work all right
you know what gonna do how do I what's
the Coastal Command to just remove again
oh I how do I get rid of this well you
could always a fast travel and pick at
it like get on Bruce and he's your he's
your manual clapping there you go
clipper where this there we go
freedom done collisions Asians back on
right where am I going
all right do you want to go and chat to
the guards and see if we can convince
one of them motley we have yeah a
friendly bunch you guys wait here I'm
amazed that that mod the the Thomas Tank
Engine one is still alive given the
aggressive breach of IP yeah I do
remember we did a whole episode cuz I
you kinda let me pick the mods on week
and I did all the Mass Effect ones and
then I think two weeks later or
something great all been taken yep yep
that was that was a running theme from
home and we did the Sonic the Hedgehog
ones and then like a week later on well
you know what cam it's funny that you
should say that oh no could you make the
Sonic 1 was was just horrendous but oh
well the blood on his face oh we can do
we can we can be bad do you want a
daytime it up a bit so that we can see
what's going on fair enough
did he time it off a bit
Matt's been in the chat for a lot of our
streams and donating a lot and he's got
to run to a zoom meeting but hopefully
enough it soon met we will allow it so
cam if you were to go into your spell's
okay spells
I have those magic and you've got seat
right at the top there can customizer
okay okay what do you think can stands
for I don't know I'm scared crimes
against crimes against nature
oh yes Oh was it the same one had the
Obama face thing oh no so wait wait
before let's take the hood off first
okay thinks it you know I'm a little
worried because this emotionally scarred
me last time we did this so well it's
gotta come up
the chicken over there Kevin hey mister
we give the red armor to Inigo but oh
absolutely buddy
you must be freezing pause I'm getting a
Hemsworth shut up and let me give you
clothes this I know
keep your filthy mitts off it okay I
don't know what I'm saying I'm just
trying what's he doing he's making
reference to the fact that you can't
lose him but like you can go anywhere
and he's like I keep finding you this
map it's incredible right right here we
go
I need to change some things of you
alright so take some clothes
give him yeah the red one okay
I already did that just day good when I
patched well okay hey look at him never
better I've only put 176 hours into
Skyrim since 2011 but haven't played
since 2014 is 2020 the year I finally
finish it yes yes see the end game
finally okay so wait what was I gonna do
again oh yeah look at this thing so I'm
a bit worried about this race menu face
editor what do you reckon any version of
these things
it also has bird okay well I like this
changing the race within a race menu
will mess up your characters leveling
process lightly okay okay right so I
think the race get ahead go ahead
yeah I'm pretty sure it oh no I did this
last time done I need to yeah yeah last
time I actually went to the presets and
tri face it's a race yeah okay try the
face one yeah alright does the same
thing okay so okay oh no anything is
this I think it there if you go across
the face I'm trying to but it's not
letting me go across
there we go sorry hey go back one get
back there ah there we go okay and now
let's cycle through them
oh we can also be a dog there oh my word
oh that is awful pretty aggressive we
don't get a hat though what's a dog okay
we were in the description on the bear
oh yeah hold Guardian what was the
what's the dogma okay
we're very friendly bogum are known for
their love
squeaky green tennis balls and their
undying belief that they are to our
people human genome in cam zoom in oh
it's a little spider a little control
with the controls dancing I hate it
Oh God overdone Hansol Hansol now go up
yeah yeah yeah whoo man which is a cat
Rose IKEA born my little pony
Oh No oh gee say something oh it's so
bad
new oh my word yeah they're the mark 2
is portal yeah there you go
oh this is the regular onset Wow okay so
Lucy would you like to choose an
abomination from co-players sure we
should put it to chat chat which of
Amida I mean or your consideration I'm a
big fan of sanic also the kitten what's
that what's the thing for Hina greetings
fellow hyun am scum do not be alarmed by
my totally normal hyun am appearance
just
another Hyun employee in doing normal
Hyun am things move along now he's kind
of like the little alien in men in black
one yeah
hailing from the northern lands of
Sweden the IKEA foreign take their name
from the endless home furnishing
labyrinths from which they emerged
oh I Catherine chat says the kitten
beard machine said like here Ritchie
says kitten a puppy
everyone's giving different pains a
Menon is saying sanic
I really go fast gotta go fast I think
you know you know ok had the best their
description text as well so also top
speech craft yeah I think he might need
to rename as well can he do this sweetie
I know you don't just accept it alright
we are an AIRAID oh my god should we
start any put a helmet on yet try it ok
hello
yeah ok or the head or whatever oh yes
now we're talking
this this is why Skyy oh god why skyrim
is the greatest game oh my god because
you can be a cat controlling a human
with its head going on that's the one
hey let me try other 10 out of 10 what
if we dress oh of course that's just
awesome that's like let me kind of hats
all the hats okay well yeah I don't have
any more hats so that's why we have
console commands okay what do you want
oh let's get me the iron helm oh yeah
well the classic one yeah yeah yeah I
need the quake ID tonight I'm getting
exciting that's why player dot add item
C learning
do you want the one of major archery
yeah well ad five nine four oh okay
Arion area not so no I'm allergic
oh look God is so sensitive but there he
is right god this is justice just about
there we go oh nice game ever
okay thank you this is absolutely the
breakout amazing all right let's go
so happy hey kiss so happy with it then
man lord where to uh I think I need to
get some combat because we want to see
what Alex yeah we definitely I mean do
you want to take on the Dragons or you
want to do that he's I think on this
lumberjack yeah he's got a weapon I
think he's a threat said oh alright here
we go let's go guys don't forget to
bring out your some magic as well can
begin this was some that's wrong one
clumsy spell oh yeah yeah exactly spell
and maybe something electric as well
electri likely electric spells look
really good yeah they do okay so you
mean you're just marks spots is good
yeah and then the end comes the
clumsiness
oh I've actually favored today of course
Oh every says can we see the kitten
shout oh yes we can
okay Daisy
nice over there okay let's do some see
sorry College guard oh god he's quite
tough yes
see Kevin was never regular magic or he
just didn't just shake heads just take
heads okay I wanted to show off all the
lovely new animations with the comedy
we'll be seeing a tiny cat decapitate a
man with the headsman's ax that's a good
point and I thought about it like that
chatter trying to come up with new names
do love it
Evan van meow yeah oh my goodness why do
you are these people and why are they
still alive greatsword I think it's
pretty better or video man young man
pause oh they're vampires is pretty good
yeah I think kitten van Lord yeah
come on I want to see it I wanted to
kill me with good great what happens a
hydroid give him meat again
do I just go is in combat oh yeah talk
to him
I can't think on bed do I drink the
nights no surely not
I don't maybe try it drink one we've got
a few there you go I was in special brew
oh it's a spell oh come on him feeling
brave Oh almost okay calm down
oh oh that's wrong one
oh yeah there you go I have transformed
them into a giant weird over there
jeez well be thinking what's so no we
need to make sure he's got more people
to kill then you have the terrifying
turn around and there's a think tank it
in imagine walking down a street at
night and seeing a giant train like that
big smile as well that does make it more
temporary something in the eyes as well
especially there's like there's a
there's a death in the eye I just over
there go
I mean just here is trouble yeah yeah
Oh what are you doing when you bring him
in some bandits to her okay I'm all help
bath or Thalmor yeah nobody likes them
night player Woods place at me what you
want
soldier wizard full your heart Lisi sold
her wizard or Jessica ah Jessica okay
ffs double zero one yet
got that much no we don't need to get it
um four double seven and many as you
like six my monies yeah that pissed them
up right go good over there
nice a good cool wow these guys are
party brought in their own a chair
well I want to get a electric effects
there I want to get a decapitation so
that we can get a close-up on the kitten
van nord taking heads let's try the I've
got balls in either hand let's try this
special things I didn't realize you
actually hold the bottle as well this is
the other one oh no I've just turned
them back into normal come on go go just
punch him punch him is he the same I
think he's the same okay either way he's
great let's see if we can get a
decapitation okay okay let me also
favorite the sword because okay great
sword or headsman's ax
I think the orc is great sword I agree
come here oh oh here we go
oh that tiny cat is no it's kind of
hoping we see the cat we can always
toggle free camera and pause get a real
a real picture of it
dovabear is if anything too powerful I
need to can we need to turn skyrim
doubts I cut Lisa I can barely hear you
over the sound of like death just going
on oh yeah you want to do that little
puns in the background
I want to hear these puns fave Skyrim is
like for all for everything it gets
right it it's like volume variation is
one of the most aggressive between there
like ah these are just like nice
peaceful moments and as soon as you get
to a fight it just like detonates your
speaker's there you go turn down a
little bit alright thank you
there we can enjoy your pause toys
oh no is it named pause inland well I
think holding that way well alright
what's next EV what what is next
I mean we still got some mud cramps and
we do the reason we came up here in the
first place was actually to go and try
and find the oh yes the the guy kill
just general guards we might need to go
to a different hold now cuz I think
we're in trouble in this hole yeah we
may have killed everybody although I
don't know we might have killed enough
people that we've we've gone full circle
back to innocent alright so you want to
try them wire and then I mean yeah sure
I feel like oh people pursuing us no COC
most-used spell get the hell out of
there
we don't get a sheer growth no that's
how much we've GBM i should shift in my
chest I've been trying to move my camera
because I I bought a new chair and it
has a footrest in it what basic it was
$130 I've ever spent
now I can't like it's like a I don't
know like an executive or how I assume
an executive would take a meeting when
you're firing people at least your legs
will be nice and rested like at least
hey
I'm spending a lot of time sitting down
I'm not gonna get a deep vein thrombosis
that's the thing yeah right yeah well
sometimes um yeah you have to where
there's like extra tight leggings or
something if you're lying now for a long
time I have been doing I'm into it I
can't find any guards cuz I killed them
all oh did we kill all of them here
this is like my new favorite thing
that's alright cats above war Oh
salmon yeah cats love salmon you know
what while we're looking for God I can
at least show off one of like a
practical model sir that's quite good so
if you were to go into perks okay I mean
I've got level up as well
yes cause yeah we have as you can see
all of our perk trees here there's a lot
more dots all legendary tons of dots on
it yeah so we've got 79 perk points to
use care feel free to have a look at
what they do
legendary anyone handy so I mean we've I
mean don't do that because we've already
at 100 on those so I would do that maybe
a different no but no but once it gets
200 in go legend yeah but we basically
what we've done is ordinator adds stacks
more of these like points on the
leveling up tree so you can basically
just increase and follow more niche
paths of what you want to be able to do
in any one of those given as well I
don't know the light armor tree well
enough to know what is well if you want
cam I can tell you about some one of the
new ones many all right well archery our
trees one we use a lot archery okay
let's go there yeah so we've added ones
like clean kill bows and crossbows deal
20% more damage to target full health
that's a low level one and let's try out
level 101 perfect aim 25% more damage if
the shot strikes target within two
seconds after the bow is fully drawn
crossbows deal triple damage to targets
with 20% or less health remaining
there's waste stacks new grants the
Lions arrow power use it to store the
spell your jewel casting shooting a
fully drawn bow and combo also releases
stored spells in the direction prepare
spell and fire it by air and
unfortunately I can era during habit
requires 90 you might need to level up
the tree that leads up to yes that's why
I'm certainly
yeah do it do it honey oh no I just
reset it to 15 well II did that so yes
you need to you need to follow the tree
up I've only got 50 never end everything
now you've got 78 no yeah you did ruin
everything
why you want to do that whoops I made a
mistake I made a huge mistake okay all
right we haven't we haven't redeemed any
perks
that's the caveman Ordway yeah these are
all year he's white yeah guys trying to
get to a hundred one that we can get
there you go it's it says you got 100
now so my eyes kinsmen all the small
words forward prior attacks with a mace
inspire nearby allies that's new yep
that's cool spray mace related my waste
power attacks with a mace I mind the
Maestri I think I might I think you're
in the mainstream we can get it we get
you amazing okay we're gonna mace tree
and then we're gonna get a mace I like
that does not work on massive targets
okay and finally whenever you defeat at
least four humanoids and/or animals in a
single battle
you gave him a permanent 1 percent boost
to one handy damage this effects stacks
up to 20%
anyway anyway this this mod basically a
bunch more like nodes on the skill tree
and maces and hopefully we'll find you a
good mace so you've got it looking at
the morkrum ace yeah was thinking maybe
that's the mace we won yes a 29 workers
are if you're not if you're unfamiliar
they kind of walrus users that was a
hawk of battle axe you added somehow and
oh you said you did 23 it's 29 well
that's it maybe I won't become ace
there we go okay let me just that's an
axe oh that's a head let's let's have a
look once it's in your hand
okay is it just because it's made of
worker bone it might be yeah which is
which is obviously makes me sad about I
was imagining the bull the mace to be
like a little Hawker head well I think
it's making it like maybe Orca tusks
it's pretty cool actually no as comedic
as I was hoping for I think there's the
day drum makes right oh that would look
oh yeah that's like one of the key
weapons right yeah more like ball you
get a Nordic mace because we've got an
actual one just over there yeah imma get
it okay alright he's off so we're gonna
get the mace of Molag Bal I remember
that being a thing oh my god there's a
lot of Macy's in this game oh my word
mm oh L AGB al o help m mo l g-o-p al
loo this was made by a cosplayer that
was a friend of one of our colleagues
because we used it in the filming of a
ridiculous video for an expansion to
Elder Scrolls online where we had a war
bear in training yes small dog with a
little chouchou puppy and our bandit
that came to attack our hero was
wielding this mace but it's beautifully
detailed an actual leather grip as well
very fat very fragile it's just really
fragile so not really a good mace no all
right where to said I have a mace of my
own there thanks to Lucy where to well
we still gotta find these these mud
crabs you don't have to you really don't
know know they're down here the right
yeah item one thing I should also
mention is that the some of the mods in
ego and
coordinator that we just looked at were
both suggested to us on Twitter well so
Inigo was suggested by Lee Brown and
ordinator was suggested by Andrew dog
day
so thanks for the recommendations guys
this way
I'm glad the cat is wearing a helmet
because this is very dangerous
yep I think so if we're gonna get into
some combat I'd say by the waters edge
otherwise we need to go to Whiterun or
similar and go and see if we can get
ourselves a chat with one of the guards
okay so basically the team wasn't ready
for a G's bike you came to strategy
right watch it yeah now you're getting
it okay so I'm gonna run down the
water's edge here the game thinks we're
in combat it's giving us combat music oh
my god are you going oh yeah that's
right you better run now I wonder if we
can talk to this garden he'll say yeah
the Faithie blind bar say the line yeah
I need you to speak the certain words to
say the words come back what happened
when you were an adventurer like me no
no it's not right it's really hard to
talk to
therefore the horns come on now this
strange cat oh this mod is called divine
punishment for mentioning arrows in the
knees amazing by TOA dime and now i
torch and steal arrows and the best bit
is that we don't get blamed for their
day yeah it's true what is this this is
like a golden moriss moriss to go away
now you know what we should probably
ride Morris anyway just so that the
dragon train engine stops come on Morris
following us fly you fool he's pretty
handy
like cold hands from Game of Thrones
spoilers doesn't work the last thing you
say I think the moratorium on Game of
Thrones spoilers is gone yeah yeah
oh I'm just absorbing a dragon soul for
some reason no yeah I like this thing
like traits top lip so I don't know how
you did that I have no idea I love
mascara is you sit down to play to show
a few minds and you wind up on the back
of an hour with a cat in your head
wearing some very fetching robes what's
gonna happen it's normally a couple of
mud crabs down here that's where they
were hunting mud crabs yeah being that's
a corker supremely elusive of them Oh
nope sorry excuse me sir don't mind me
yeah yeah just this your average cat man
running an elk
nothing to see here where is are these
crabs right should we just bring some in
yeah oh you know what I've I was trying
to mess around with the mods earlier
there's it's entirely possible I broke
this one okay help crowd okay
giant oops palace' me that's not gonna
do it
hey which one said let's just go with FF
double zero one eb1 okay now annoyingly
I wanted to have them look slightly
different and they were supposed to
happen they're really really chatty the
reef pinchy try it try giving one a
little kick I think it said something I
cannot it's as a man so tell I think it
was like that was someone else I think
it was a real good air on that one that
you hit from horseback yeah I think
their thing they are swearing yeah
turn up dialogue maybe okay oops very
little crap they're just they're
horrible bastard crabs okay just just
crank them from the voice and volume for
this one okay okay okay this is meant to
be a two-part like it's just a really
crap bit that works okay fair enough
they're meant to be wearing like top
they're meant to be wearing top hats
these are good guys they're good boys
oh sorry I didn't mean to
there we go she's it
Oh oh my word there's so many of them
yes of course of course sort of look
because we got a ride we got a ride this
always ends up Kevin chooses the chicken
oh if I recall cam this is it does it
still have that same weird like bug
where if you go into toggle free cameras
yeah we go at Agra free camera I think
the chicken still runs so you can delay
these amazing epic shots I'm a chicken
going into the sunset Oh God
Oh oh sorry sorry everybody and here we
see the humble chicken ridden by doc in
the wall god reverse I want the cube
around him to turn you can do it that's
right Oh spin it back where is he yet
where is he oh he's still on the cliff
okay he's a little stuck he's all stuck
you got to give him some turning he'll
go okay let's go back to him for a sec
because he's too many rocks around here
oh I think we're actually stuck actually
just run him clean until I know we're
fine hey we're good we're good was if I
I will let me rag doll while in the back
of the chicken can you oh no I just got
off no general under like the developers
of this game they see stuff like this
and then just kind of sigh sadly to
themselves it's like I spent yeah yeah
making this Jam realistic and you're
riding you just made a 10 foot tall and
make it explode look alright my favorite
thing about the chicken is it looks like
it's putting in so much effort like it
should be actually and then but it's
really not going very fast at all like
talk about your kind of energy from it
right now Det we got a briefing on you a
little message up there but our
one-handed damage oh I was really
worried about what happened to a
farmer's immersive armor configuration
what's going on and up so if you want I
can run you through some of the other
like mods that we firm we've put on like
obviously that doing most of the mods
that we've got here are ones that are
really easy to see and do some really
weird and wonderful things but we do
have about 150 other mods on as well and
I reckon like for the most part most of
the mods are there to just improve the
immersion and basically max out what the
game is capable capable of running yeah
because the game in it's like vanilla
state uses sort of like like 500 pixel
style mixtures for four images which is
pretty low res and you know as you run
around the game in its vanilla state it
can look a bit sort of janky and no just
kind of looks like it needs needs more
love and life so a lot of these are just
simply taking a lot of the textures and
just cranking them up to 4k and I mean
you're not really gonna notice it in
most of the gameplay you're certainly
not gonna notice it on our compression
through the through the screen or guys
[Laughter]
those red oh no it's it's blood splat I
was like of the eyes gone red oh that
was a good hit didn't hit anything vital
oops oh my god it's alright it's gone
it's gone he's a million shot though too
okay we got him is there any other mods
on he's still hitting the chicken yeah
get off winch again is it time to bring
in some exploding chickens to figure
this out so yeah I mean the only other
mods we've got are pretty minor so such
as well I did
a mod that gives us new bandoliers
across our cross our body and like I
suppose most of all of these that we've
been kind of skipping like the quest
that you do to get them for the most
part I like that there's a lot of law
that's been baked into tons these mods
maybe not so much the like the
ridiculous ones but a bunch of the other
mods like even the clumsiness ones
there's you know follow this story arc
to find things properly rather than just
bring things in in console commands we
we just cheat them that way yeah all
right running away from that fight no
this one doesn't I try to work Oh are
they wearing
no they just gold well unfortunately the
top hat crabs were where Ellie sometimes
it works and sometimes he doesn't for
the most part it doesn't fact is this
mod so dovabear is an ally mod that one
works useful dragon Susan Ellie mod that
does also seem to which is surprising is
we do have another mod on called diverse
dragons and it doesn't seem so far to be
clashing for some reason said yeah our
chicken more cool is not working what
ain't no money zero right yeah oh no it
is it's totally where'd you get it wrong
all right calm down yeah it still work
it's working absolutely fine game yeah
it's all good okay two other mods I mean
that we can we can skip one for sure
which is it's called the rich merchants
rich Skyrim merchants and as just a
general gameplay mod it is a super super
useful mod it simply helps you like rut
like push through the game that little
bit faster because every time you go
over to a merchant especially in the
early game they're only a few merchants
that will buy anything off you Bella
Thor being probably the the best one in
Whiterun you'll buy literally anything
but at in the early game like if you go
up to a
Smith who sells weapons they'll only buy
weapons off you or armor you won't be
able to sell them like random trash that
you found around the like dungeons and
things he looted so being able to
basically enable this modern to go like
I want to give all of the merchants
either just like a little bump or a
significant bump in their purchasing
power of you yeah it's just a handy mod
it's not a not a completely game
breaking one and it you know and it
isn't also a tiny cat controlling you
somewhere in there yes and it's nice
little middle ground there yeah but yeah
we've also got bandoliers as well bags
and pouches classic alright and how do
we do this one this one we can do we can
either find them or can take don't get
crazy man okay let's have a look
will you see it strike twice yes can
craft them at a tanning rack I believe
there's a tanning rack I just passed one
just in Riverwood before is that just
just that the outside the gates is there
here we can see the lanterns of Skyrim
and there's also and hover mod enables
and I think it's just called blowing in
the wind which makes things blow in the
wind
look I appreciate that it's just names
you know say what you see catch rate
rules I like to think apart from a few
of the like megaquest mods largely all
the mods in the game just do very very
very very specific things combat fight
game in in any way this is Kevin's curse
it's just like forever in combat mode
press X to see where we reverse and hold
X on the keyboard yeah see anyone he's
trying to kill us oh that's probably one
worth mentioning we're easing immersive
HUD I HUD which basically you can toggle
on and toggle off the bits of the HUD
that you want to see although not the
MCM menu oh yeah
and sky UI which is the different
interface the menu interface that using
it for which is awesome give you a new
cell to jump to the rift ECOC rift in
that work let me get you a code for mark
R okay well well away from there try COC
Markov origin no space o origin will get
us out of there all of our running
around has got us into too many fights
that we can't get out of done number one
everybody millennia than I was expecting
yeah it was always gonna happen now you
know that's yeah that's pretty good
when you mods going oh man like to amend
the crash counter yes who was one yeah
we've got more heads did already hit
play so surprising I waited oh you
didn't I was waiting for it to stop
spinning foreign previously so yeah I
did
I was I was super panicking there cuz I
I saw you hit play and I was like that's
it that's it mmm well sorry chat then
and now you'll see how long it takes to
load when you have this many mods on it
does take its toll I think like on mods
in general if if your favorite way of
playing Skyrim is to just mod it up the
wazoo and do ridiculous things kind want
to play the original version of skyrim
legendary because the number of mods
that are on the Nexus yeah like a lot of
modders
like years passed before special edition
came out and a lot of the modders just
either like left the scene or they just
couldn't be bothered to like port them
across so ton its mods never made it
into special edition and while you know
Bethesda net has a bunch of mods on
there that make it really really easy to
mod like you don't need to you don't
need to install vortex and all of these
like you know more complicated ways of
modding you can literally go into the
game select mods choose mods install
they go they are really restricting on
what they will allow there's like file
size limits and everything as well so I
think if you want like the ultimate
modders paradise it is the original
edition that you want what is the
difference between legendary and special
edition yeah so well legendary edition
was the original all-in-one package of
Skyrim and half fires and Dragonborn
and Dawnguard which were the three like
main expansions that came with it and
that ran on like a help me out chat
northern I'm reading chat but it's
basically the the special edition was
the 64 bit version of the game so I
guess it was the x86 version of the game
so it makes more use of oh oh listen
Khan again she's unstable
oh God what were you doing I typed help
shoulder pad alright before we load back
in cam go - sorry doesn't matter
well we're gonna say go - I was gonna
say we could we can sort of like purge
and redeploy the mod sometimes that
cheers it up purge mods I don't know if
you want to do this well the game is
loading as to see if the game loads
first it's coming back guys yeah yeah
load load a different save maybe before
we thought
okay before we I'm blaming the Train I
think the Train is probably making
things tricky what was the hurry so
Henry I think is the big green train and
James is the red one yeah James is the
is the face that I will see him when
nightmares tonight oh yeah you're
welcome the world this was like
beginning today we do this one sure yeah
we can always bring dovabear in and take
him with us on a flight oh we will see
see what I've done is that can we should
like I should have put this the other
way around cuz I'm looking over here on
camera yeah we're lucky this way wait
now I'm said look up and can look down
to talk to each other hey hey hey SEP
yeah it's good this is the top quality
content you can expect a mess okay
you've always been riding on my
shoulders hey Kerry Kerry uh we are
bringing in our chicken Oh actually I
was gonna bring in the buddleja that's
why I was like it that's why I was
trying to help shoulder do I dare do it
again yeah try it
help Wanderlei a shoulder but I want
this shoulder pad there we go okay
no eighties fashion for you player soft
tailoring is what Kevin's all about
large bandoliers shoulder pad su-47 oh
it's too many seven zero zero one eight
three four - all right let's see what
that looks like so this is part of the
the bandoliers mod you're saying so
actually that's actually awesome so it's
not just aesthetic it does boost your
overall carry weight as well that's so
you can start with like small little
belts that I think add about 50 to your
carry weight all the way up to like
full-sized bandoliers that add a hundred
do we have you need them on this Hanning
rack
have the van Lord Armour in here we
don't Oh van Nord armor hello MPC series
your should Kevin Bernard
I think that's us there's an MPC no I'm
pretty you can try it
7/7 space one know like it's Kevin
Bernard oh hey pal did we get the weird
echo when you talk to him no I just know
he just rumbles no I don't understand
what he's very zen a lot of namaste z'
there yeah Oh mad now these chills and
care okay well we can take a lot of
Kevin's and a lot of chickens on our on
our eyes gonna we're gonna bring in some
different clothing as I was gonna do but
then nevermind okay so is it is it
launch time is it is that is that the
time we got thing up 15 minutes more of
the stream we we were time for another
if there are any any particular fights
people would like to see us get into
now's the time let me
yeah requests time I think and then we
will do a good old launch at the end as
is the way oh thank you I've got a
donation from Josh Brown 25 bucks to
black lives matter thank you very much
awesome thanks Josh awesome Josh
fantastic all right mmm
is there any more mods on the list or
have we that's that's all are ridiculous
mods okay okay yeah see we also have
what's the magic mod that we just have
proof yeah apocalypse
which I'll find for you because that
adds about 350 spells which is sound
don't even think of this as a mod
because we always have it on but it's
yeah probably the ultimate most powerful
smog that we've got again so yeah it
adds in fact ah ah ah I just went to the
mod page and it's got a little video
example and it's from a website called
gamespot.com oh yeah and their show
Skyrim mods
what a treat what a treat okay can you
fly on a dragon can we fly on a dragon
we are we certainly need to fight the
Dragons because we need to bring them
all there yeah yeah just understand
saving this bandit from these these
horrible dogs does that is that only off
first head I can open can you get the
clumsy spell on someone else or is it
only on you I think it is on let me let
me get you the spell back it's it's
quick oh yeah
it is called y'all need to go help and
fine oh yeah was the term wasn't it yeah
yeah and at home but the tome has a name
okay so search for help
dexterous de XD er thank you for
assuming I need that spells preciate it
when he did I get a place at me again
okay forty double zero one to c7
okay look what I just happen to find
them for look in the middle of the woods
I know how lucky let's give that a quick
read right
magic clumsiness yeah it seems to be
just a it defaults to the shout so
there's any way to make it targets both
but yeah that would make it much speed
much better yeah pretty sure there is
there is a spell that you can use to
just like knock people over like that
hmm
all right so we want to fight the
Dragons right Oh asks to fly on one
fairy flying one right can we ride
herbal dragons it is it's well we've got
all the moves yeah
not just the mounts but we've got which
expansion added rideable dragon oh yeah
yeah but it's a shout that we need that
calls one you know what it is oh I
remember playing it Skyrim was in funny
enough was in Dragonborn what was the
name of it help of the bend will shout
oh is that it bend will Bend will okay
mm-hmm it's a spell as well thank you
Michael in the chat same bend will yeah
Thank You chat 0 4 0 1 if 1 e 1 I guess
up didn't work what I do you wrong 1 D
what do you what you can add a spell no
is it learn spell sorry Claire don't
learn spell I think it it's ad spell not
learn um no get rid of the one oh yeah
hey ok well done magic
be interesting to see if this works
though you know there is a way
there is a way to add like console
command in shouts and enable them but I
can't remember it off the top of my head
does not seem to be in here yeah because
I've got there I've got the spell sorry
I've got the shout IDs as well but why
don't you just blow some things up and
I'll try and think all right go for an
upgrade of well well what were you gonna
blow up we were gonna blow up well we
need to bring in the bring in like all
the dragons bring in Elder win as well
so which one is Thomas is it okay place
at me actually I need to do help al do
it with girls
yep and then let's also just bring in
some an assortment of dragons what's the
console come on four assortment of
noggins you could make a batch fire and
do that yeah you can really remake like
files that you can trigger that with
just summon in whatever you let that's
actually probably the most useful thing
in this whole this whole stream would be
to say that like you can make these
console commands into a text file that
you just changed to a dot bat file and
then you just list all of the commands
that you want done in order so we used
to have one that was like bat Kevin and
it was it was toggle god mode toggle off
toggle free camera because we'd have
that on from the last save then it would
set the weather you can like add a load
of gold and you basically just go to the
dump bang and like all of this stuff
happens so that and then you can just
like tweak it and change it and people
live on like the Skyrim Nexus for
example people have made pre-made batch
files that are really helpful for
example there are ones that like Auto
level you up to a hundred because it's
something that you normally have to do
like one by one by one by one like add
this spell add this spell add this spell
so you can just
toggle that on and then bang you're off
what the hell was that a lot of things
happen one of them oh I brought a lava
dragon because always snow that was and
yes this is the kind of chaos I was here
for there are there are other drag like
Tomas dragons why is it so bright
Oh all the old emotes are getting
involved good guys they are one of the
vampires from Dawnguard and that's the
Dragonborn someone's singing I think oh
is it I take it it's not playing the
Thomas the Tank Engine theme song it's
playing something something oh yeah did
he turn into mine cards when you kill
them I guess this is a version of hell
is he still here I know he's up there
wait what's the name of this mod this
dream this mod is called really useful
dragons yeah and again you'll find this
on the regular Skyrim Nexus not on
special edition Nexus give him a reason
to come down camp dude it's very hard to
hit him he's very fast you can don't
forget you can toggle free camera one
and go and visit him as well let's have
a was gonna because I'm what my screens
all like gleam nice yeah this is marcin
imagine I never thought these worlds
would ever collide I know I don't think
anyone did him he also looks like if the
other one looked like he'd seen some
stuff Thomas looks like you've done some
stuff why did they need all of that like
shading around his eyes like like he
hasn't slept in
you know yeah that is horrendous his
victims yeah well can you ride him the
og I'm not sure if you can ride alder
win angry at me but we could and I was
gonna say we can get the other we can
ride the other dragon but he won't take
off I don't think yeah I think he's
walking dragon only give it a go
all right James or Drago apparently so
is is he is the only you normally not an
engine he's just a dragon okay
normally this is a dragon which is why
it's called Drago I love the fact that
it's wheels are moving let's go by the
way tree can you throw him out of the
sky off the back of a mean yeah of a
train I just hate you at full zoom out I
love thee it looks like he's kind of
galloping off the back of it oh oh you
like a challenge
that's never happening alright I think
it's I think it might be a chicken
launch time yeah it's dovabear still
with us
I can I can always bring him in and you
know go as well stuck on the dragon do
they have collisions just collision your
way out here we go now you're out so you
need go Inigo lion ITA inigo montoya
that's my head Canon I think it's
correct
again key going man got a lot of
dialogue he's got so much time Wow oh my
goodness that was oh we have we hit the
top nope where is he I think there's
only so much it can show us what we have
to go and get him
oh if we just do it help and then put
him in rotation works I don't think
that's gonna change it nope nope
definitely did not at all okay fine uh
yeah I don't think he's gonna be joining
us guys
that's alright don't you go over there
that's fine don't really was here I
brought over there in that this is what
we get for having such a thorough mod
with so much dialogue we can't even get
the NPC code help this last time beer
there is you can quickly change yourself
to sanic as well oh great idea
sanic what how it fails us again
oh okay he's and he's enraged for him
full full rage oh yeah and they do the
magic we've already got this yeah there
you go customizer
open race editor face editor yeah and up
and across I've gone down oh yay
gotta go fast what this fake user take
his armor off as well oh okay are you
sure I did oh I just want to know why
did we leave this to Lush he's gonna
keep the I show you let me do the arrows
off as well and then yeah okay
oh that's very light isn't it oh that's
very aggressive wait take the bandolier
off - why did why do these arms run
behind him
no it's dad I'm Naruto running really
fast
you gotta get the whole song in cam okay
I just go turn it I feel like it's
blowing out everyone's speakers just me
okay good okay okay here we go
I love you sighs no feedback this bed
yeah you better run he's running with
the deer oh my god I don't buddy oh good
idea good idea good idea oh I was gonna
start from the beginning again isn't it
bad
[Music]
and it keeps playing while you're it's
just like tossing a wet towel my brain
hurts
if you saw that running at you full pelt
[Music]
that is horrendous isn't it oh all right
it's like you want me to get rid of this
mostly let's get some chicken down oh my
word that is we did 100 yeah we need 100
oh wow oh she set us off dude you can
see all the wind in the toys just just
clipped out oh wow bouncy walk they done
test bones he didn't drink he always
drinks enough milk Richards vitamin ah
this is awful big it in poor I think
that's my favorite mud see if you can
give us one more chicken launch ramen
and see if you can act all yourself into
into it I don't know how how am I gonna
do it and set it off you know mm-hmm so
he's not I rely on them them to kill
themselves they would be possible is
there any time detonation thing in sky I
don't know I bolt lemon see what well we
need a we need the rune you know like
the trap rune Leah and the challenge
it's just gone that's just wrong
everything about it I don't disagree
yeah okay let me try one thing I think
we might build a chicken fuse a bit here
if we use the flame spell
you could try the fire ring and I think
the flames I don't think it our chicken
I'll set it off my D yes I go pre
rag-dolled
yet yeah are you gonna make it all the
way back to her to Whiterun where anyway
he's like getting gradually longer as he
falls yeah well I'm glad that this is
what we could bring back to you back to
games but I miss you quality serious
video game coverage thank you so much
for joining us on today's stream thank
you to everyone who's been watching and
in the chat and donating so much fun Seb
cam thank you so much where can people
find you you can find us over on YouTube
cam and Seb very easy to remember we
still play a lot Skyrim and other games
too yeah we do be very welcome but thank
you very much for having us Lisi and
thank you again to everyone who donated
on the stream that was absolutely
awesome
it's always fun for us to be able to
jump back into this game like as
ridiculous as it is as old as it is we
still managed to find like loads of fun
it and so it's always a treat to play
with with whoever oh I just know it's
his stomach we didn't want this to be
nice
hey guys the immersive armor
configuration is finished oh alright
thank you everyone for watching we'll be
back again in actually about an hour
we're gonna be doing some movie trivia
with Jack Costello from roosterteeth
Achievement Hunter you won't want to
miss it
thanks again 7 cam we'll see you soon
guys
[Music]
you
[Music]